Привет! В прошлых уроках мы разобрали, на чём вообще собирают продукты, что конкретно нам нужно в нашем проекте, почему мы пользуемся React, и в целом, как нам всё это дело собирать.
Теперь самое интересное — заставляем агента писать настоящий код. Берём твою дизайн-систему и превращаем её в React-проект с компонентной базой. Это та самая зеркальная копия. Твои компоненты Figma становятся компонентами в коде.
Как обычно, уже готова директива, которую мы будем запускать, но прежде чем это сделаем, давай разберёмся, как это зеркало устроено. Это стоит понять, чтобы дальше осмысленно направлять агента, а не гадать, что он там сделал.
Смотри, источник истины у нас один — это твоя дизайн-система. Живёт она в Figma и продублирована в проекте папкой DS. Напомню, что в этой папке у нас Foundation — это токены, Components — это каталог компонентов с вариантами и контракты.
Правила сборки. Три файла, которые вместе дают полное описание твоей системы. Агент работает по ним.
Теперь как одно ложится на другое? Переменная из Figma становится токеном в коде с тем же именем.
Figma-компонент становится React-компонентом с тем же именем и теми же вариантами.
Button Figma — Button в коде.
Какой-нибудь токен Surface Default Figma точно так же называется Surface Default в коде.
В прошлом уроке мы говорили, что React-компонент по сути то же самое, что компонент Figma.
Тут это и срабатывает буквально. У нас не только общая структура и внешний вид, но и общее название.
В дальнейшем это позволяет агенту быстро ориентироваться по всем компонентам. Это очень важно.
Дальше главный вопрос этой связки — то, о чем часто спрашивают: «Ты поменял что-то в Figma, что происходит в коде?»
Ничего. Сам по себе код не обновиться сейчас — это сделать невозможно.
Никак этот процесс ты не автоматизируешь.
Поэтому, если ты вносишь какие-то обновления, нужно сообщать об этом агенту.
Если ты это все делаешь вручную, если ты делаешь это с помощью него, то он сам все собирает и сам все это дело записывает.
Чем конкретнее указываешь, что поменял, тем быстрее будет этот процесс.
И также это может работать в обратном порядке.
Сегодня мы соберем ряд компонентов сразу в реакте, собранными в коде.
Если ты создаешь какие-то новые сразу на прототипе — такое тоже бывает.
Я, например, вообще Figma практически перестал пользоваться.
Сразу собираю продукты на реакте с агентом.
Но и в таком случае, если ты что-то делаешь сразу в проде, можешь в обратном порядке попросить его добавить.
Добавить это в Figma.
И еще один важный момент — это то, какая у тебя база.
Во втором модуле ты собирал свою дизайн-систему либо с нуля, либо на готовой опенсорсной основе.
Например, ShadeCN — это сейчас самая популярная.
Если у тебя опенсорсная база, для тебя все еще проще.
У таких библиотек, как правило, есть не только Figma Kit, но и открытая библиотека на реакте.
То есть компоненты все те же самые, что были в Figma уже собраны, уже написаны.
Можно попросить агента просто подключить соответствующую библиотеку, в данном случае ShadeCN, и у тебя, по сути, все твои компоненты уже перенесены.
Однако, если ты что-то менял в Figma в этих компонентах, как ты их немного кастомизировал под себя, возможно, цвета какие-то, перемены семантические менял, переназначал, об этом, конечно, нужно агенту сообщить.
Если же ты ничего не менял, то, по сути, просто предупреждаешь, что работаем ShadeCN, и на этом все.
У меня же в CryptoVPS база своя, визуал свой, готовой реализации нет, поэтому агент будет собирать компоненты сам по описанию SDS.
Как обычно, выбирают директиву, сейчас она называется ReactBase, и прошу его запустить ее.
Директива отработала, он собрал все эти компоненты, и сейчас нам предлагает на локалке посмотреть, как это работает, как это выглядит.
Сразу отмечу вообще, что такое локалка, я часто это упоминаю, что я имею под этим в виду.
Любой сайт в интернете, он хранится на каком-то сервере.
Где-то существует этот сервер, у него есть свой айпишник, на нем хранится этот сайт, и когда кто-то хочет на него зайти, посмотреть, ты там вписываешь домен и так далее, но на самом деле тебя направляет на этот сервер.
Сервер, у которого там есть айпи.
И что такое локалка?
Локалка - это локальный сервер.
Он как бы симулирует только для тебя, что вот этот сайт уже в лайве дает зайти через браузер на него, и как будто это реальный сайт.
Но на самом деле он реальный только для тебя, то есть он локально у тебя.
Этот сервер существует, ты можешь зайти и посмотреть, но если ты эту ссылку кому-то другому перешлешь, в его локальной сети этого не будет, он не сможет по ней перейти.
Как задеплоить вообще на свой сервер, как это все выглядит, мы посмотрим в другом уроке.
Сейчас просто объясняю, что вообще такое локалка.
Итак, он сам запустил локальный сервер, можно скопировать эту ссылочку, открыть браузер и просто по ней перейти.
Вот он собрал нам foundations, собрал вообще список этих компонентов, какие-то самые базовые анимации.
Мы теперь по нему можем пройтись и отметить, все ли тут хорошо, все ли тут аккуратно собрано.
Это такой вид непрофессиональный, можно сказать.
Еще нужно здесь отрабатывать логику, первый, второй, третий, переключение страниц, переключение табов, переход по ссылкам и так далее.
А здесь базово уже развернуты все основные механизмы, даже какие-то ховер-эффекты есть.
То есть основная компонентная база с всеми foundations сюда перенесена.
Дальше, если что-то не так, что-то нас не устраивает, пишем агенту и выравниваем вот этот визуал, чтобы все совпадало.
Но здесь, как я могу судить, прям вообще все он перенес идеально.
Ну и чтобы далеко не ходить, не смотреть в браузере, ты можешь смотреть все это дело прямо здесь.
Ты можешь здесь через ctrl+shift+p открыть команды и найти вот команду browser.
quick open browser tab и нажать new integrated browser tab.
Все, у тебя открылся браузер прямо здесь внутри.
И сюда эту ссылку можно ввести и работать сразу здесь внутри VS кода со своим вот этим прототипом.
Это очень удобно.
Не нужно менять окно, сразу здесь даешь все правки, смотришь, что все работает.
Итак, это первичный такой быстрый прогон.
На самом деле только половина пути по одной страничке ты не проверишь там.
Каждый компонент, все его вариации, все его состояния, как он отрабатывает вообще во всех ситуациях.
В целом пробегаться в таком виде не слишком удобно.
Ну и уже не говоря о том, что разработчику это ты не отдашь.
Для этого у нас есть storybook.
Это как раз формат оформления вот подобной базы компонентов.
Это нужно, чтобы уже с React библиотеками работать полноценно и передавать их своим разработчикам.
Как это выглядит и как его собрать мы посмотрим уже в следующем уроке.
В качестве домашки тебе нужно точно также создать уже свою базу в коде.
В качестве домашки тебе тоже нужно прогнать директиву, создать наконец вот эту базу в коде и проверить чисто визуально, что все нормально перенеслось.
После чего достаточно просто сделать скрин вот этого получившегося документа у себя на локалке и отправить в Zen Class.
На этом все. Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания и до встречи в следующем уроке.